you just don't succeed in any endeavor
unless you've got a team that's been
supporting it and that's part of my
political philosophy it's really based
on my own experience which was if
somebody hadn't been out there looking
out for me starting with my mom my
grandmother my grandfather then I
wouldn't made it you know it wasn't
because of my brilliance or something
that these things happen it had to do
with people investing in you and so
we've got to make sure we're investing
in the next generation just like
somebody invested in us I want to
highlight two main problems with that
old tired me first approach to life
first of all it distracts you from
what's truly important and it may lead
you to compromise your values and your
principles and your commitments think
about it it's in chasing titles and
status in worrying about the next
election rather than the national
interest and the interests of those who
you're supposed to represent that
politicians so often lose their ways in
Washington they spend time thinking
about polls but not about principle it
was in pursuit of gaudy short-term
profits and the bonuses that came with
them that so many folks lost their way
on Wall Street engaging in extraordinary
risks with other people's money
in contrast the leaders we Revere the
businesses and institutions that last
they are not generally the result of a
narrow pursuit of popularity or personal
advancement but of devotion to some
bigger purpose
the preservation of the union or the
determination to lift a country out of a
depression the creation of a quality
product a commitment to your customers
your workers your shareholders and your
community that's the hallmark of real
success you just watch - amazing clips
from Barack Obama take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]